we're hearing from people who worked
inside the Russian troll factory named
in special counsel Robert Muller's
indictment the indictment identified 13
Russians who allegedly tried to
influence the 2016 presidential election
using social media Elizabeth Palmer
spoke with a young activist who got a
job in the factory she is in st.
Petersburg with how the activist hopes
the trolls can be brought to justice
Elizabeth good morning good morning
the Russian government has pushed back
fiercely against charges of trolling US
citizens in the run-up to the
presidential elections but not all
Russians are in denial about it
we spoke to Ludmila South Shore an
activist who went underground in 2015 to
get a job in the by now infamous troll
Factory she was horrified by the
round-the-clock operation including
night shifts and depressed by the
Kremlin align propaganda aimed at
Russians as well as Americans what did
you think when you saw the American
indictment and myself whether stuck Oi I
felt as if it brought me back to life
draws here are never punished so the
u.s. indictment was a first step in
bringing these people who are basically
criminals to justice softer told us the
trolls based in the office building on
savushkin a street are still hard at
work what American ski project yes the
US operation may have wound down but she
says now the trolls are churning out
pictures and fake news aimed at turning
Russian public opinion against Americans
fighting that can be risky
are you afraid for yourself now if I am
to stay safe I can't answer that
question
at the end of that interview Ludmila had
a question for us how likely is it she
asked that the 13 people named in the
indictment would ever face us justice
and we had to tell her there is almost
no chance because the Russians are
extremely unlikely to extradite them
Gail right Elizabeth Palmer in st.
Petersburg thank you